saudi-led coalition airstrikes haven't
had much effect on the Houthi advance on
Yemen's port city of Aden southern
Yemeni militias are now fighting
desperate street to street battles
against the rebel fighters we spoke to
the middle east analyst at naval curry
from the rafik hariri center on the
Atlantic Council the intervention was a
bit late in that some force should have
been placed around aidan before the who
thiz got to it now that the who these
are inside the fighting is simply too
costly to damaging to civilian life and
infrastructure and at this point it may
be a very difficult and costly thing to
get the hoodies out of it I think the
Saudi goal is to show enough strength to
drive the hoodies back to the bargaining
table the air campaign has achieved
about all it can achieve right now which
is getting rid of strategic assets which
the Houthi is gained from the Yemeni
army at this point it's very hard to
pursue fighters on the ground with
sophisticated jet fighters so the only
next logical thing in the war effort is
for them to put people on the ground and
that wouldn't necessarily get the
hoodies to surrender I think the Saudi
goals right now are unrealistic they
seek healthy surrender giving up their
weapons leaving Salah all as a
precondition to talking that is not a
realistic goal I don't think the hokies
will do that any time soon even though
Iran is now quite vested in the hokies
in Yemen I don't think Iran would risk a
direct confrontation with Saudis simply
because they know the Americans are
them the Iranians will try to assist as
best they can I think there has been a
failure repeatedly by the Saudis and
unfortunately by the US government as
well the conflict where the Ruthie's
could have been mediated even before
2011 after 2011 as they started marching
towards the capital something could have
been done then but American diplomacy
has been very inadequate in the last
five six years and the Saudis are not
really the ones to mediate since they
have a vested interest in Yemen but they
have not been very helpful to the
catteries and hermione's who have wanted
to try i would say that there is always
a chance for diplomacy at this late
stage in the game the US government
should be taking the lead in pushing
mediation rather than in supporting the
Saudi war effort further